by ils sont très nombreux en fait et
c'est pour ça que le groupe des verts et
des pirates
et pas tout à fait satisfait avec le la
directive de la commission même si
effectivement c'est une première ces
précurseurs et heureusement comment ça
existe mais pour nous ça ne va pas assez
loin parce que les risques ils sont
qu'aujourd'hui les algorithmes dont
monsieur te d'orage parler qui conquit
qui sont la conception des applications
que nous utilisons dans nos téléphones
dans nos ordinateurs mais que les
entreprises utilisent pour de plus en
plus de ses services ses applications
elles ont été deux manières
général construite élaboré par par des
hommes par des hommes blancs par des
hommes blancs d'un certain âge et d'un
milieu aisé et sa salle influence en
fait toute la construction de ces
algorithmes alors il ya des exemples
connus qui sont amazon en 2018 on a
réalisé que le système d'embauché
d'amazones des classes est
systématiquement toutes les femmes parce
que l'algorithme avaient été ainsi conçu
on sait aussi qu'en termes de polices
prédictive par exemple c'est extrêmement
dangereux donc on arrête régulièrement
aux etats-unis aujourd'hui des gens qui
ne sont pas du tout coupable simplement
parce qu'ils ont à peu près les traits
que la machine qu'on soit pour le pour
le suspect parce que la banque de
données que l'application utilise c'est
une bande de donner deux visages
masculins homme s est elle en a et des
hommes blancs elle en a pleins pleins
mais des hommes maghrébins et ou noir
elle en a très peu et puis alors si on
passe aux femmes elle en a aussi très
très peu donc elle va confondre toutes
les femmes elle va confondre tous les
hommes qui n'ont pas des traits blancs
et du court régulièrement on se retrouve
avec des gens qui sont accusés à tort où
on se retrouve avec des gens qui sont
discriminés on dit que les algorithmes
sont racistes et sexistes c'est pas les
algorithmes eux-mêmes évidemment mais la
manière dont ils ont été conçus sont les
fonds qu'ils sont souvent très
discriminatoire
[Musique]